[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein Name ist hen satler ich bin 62
Jahre alt und bin seit 12 Jahren
Bürgermeister der stadtlf geism bin sehr
zufrieden und sehr glücklich in diesem
Job und ich bin beharlich dabei das
große Projekt bber vorne zu treiben und
mit aller Kraft mich
einzusetzen wenn man das hinbekämen das
wäre sowas
[Musik]
großartiges
komm das werden wir hinkriegen wir
freuen uns drauf also wir haben uns ja
vorher schon mal verständigt gehabt dass
du das ganze moderierst anmoderierst
dass du begrüßt ja und erteilst dann den
Bürgermeister zum Aufgalopp das Wort ne
die Leute werden munter Nase aufsperren
weil sie von der dem Ausmaß
überrascht sind vielleicht sogar
erschlagen sind ne wir haben eigentlich
eigentlich ganz ernst sogar gesagt
eigentlich keine Schwachstelle die
einzige Schwachstelle ist richtnet das
nicht ein bisschen F hier in diesem Land
aber auch DAF meine
Antwort so jetzt muss ich mal meine
gelbe Krawatte anziehen ich darf mal
kurz verschwinden
Jaen ja gleich gleich gleich was ist das
denn bisschen Kritik ach das ist nicht
schlecht ist do nicht schlecht Kritik
ist
gut die antiströmung
hier Kritik bevor die wissen es
geht n gut dass ich bei mein meinem
Mutter gelernt hab wie man mich
[Musik]
weitert denn bei so vielen Herrschaften
muss man das ist eine Sache der der des
Respekts der Sicherheit
ne was schben die jetzt hier Hoffnung
für 2000 CDU wahlkampfschau verschlingt
über 250 000 Steuergelder was hat das
mit unserem Projekt jetzt zu
tun kann ich nicht
erkennen so so ist gut macht mich
schlank denn senkrecht macht schlank auf
in den
Kamp ach so sie sind der der der
Künstler der Architekt ja das ist gut
das ist immer gut ja ich habe 25 Jahre
in der Wohnungswirtschaft verbracht
vielleicht können sie mich anstellen als
betriebsabrechnerin wir schaffen 900
Arbeitsplätze 900 schön Wein ja und sch
guten Abend meine sehrhrten Damen und
Herren mit deiner Freunde herzlich
willkommen ich gebe jetzt das Mikrofon
an unseren Bürgermeister bitteschön Herr
Bürgermeister meine sehr vererehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Mitbürgerinnen
und Mitbürger ich freue mich
unwahrscheinlich dass so viele
Interesse daran haben neugierig
sind Informationen bekommen möchten
über ein
Projekt was sicherlich eines der
ehrgeizigsten eines der größten feren
und
freizeitprojekte der Republik werden
wird wir haben fünf Hotels und wir haben
fünf Golfplätze und wir haben eine
künstliche Wasserfläche und und und wir
brauchen einfach wer Urlaub macht
braucht das Wasser braucht die Blaue
Lagune das wird weberberg komplett
verändern das stellen wir uns in etwa so
vor ins Wasser gebaut man fährt sogar
unter dem Hotel mit dem Ruderboot durch
man kann sogar durchschwimmen
entlang dieser vielen
wasserlagunen bauen wir
Häuser die Häuser sind direkt am Wasser
teilweise sogar auf dem
Wasser und wir haben vor fast 400
solcher Häuschen zu verkaufen und die
sind alle touristisch wir können uns
jetzt vorstellen dass wir mit diesem
Projekt was ein bisschen wie Schloss
versaai anmutet das Vorzeigeprojekt für
Tourismus in Deutschland schaffen werden
wir sind keine visionäre wir sind keine
Spinner denn wir schaffen der
Bürgermeister hat vorhin gesagt aus den
acht Arbeitsplätzen schaffen wir 1000
direkt und 1000 weitere
indirekt also da wird für jeden Arbeit
geben für
jeden und hier ist jetzt jeder
eingeladen nicht nur eingeladen sondern
wir hoffen darauf dass jeder kommt denn
wir brauchen euch wir brauchen sie zum
Speisen essen trinken und
Vergnügen der Reihe nach werden wir die
Frag abrufen gehen Sie bitte einfach zu
dem
Mikrofon bitön sie sind ja guten Abend
mein
Name
für die Gemeinden bberbeck und saberburg
das Konzept wirkt ja in sich sehr
schlüssig und das ist ja auch
professionell heute abend uns
präsentiert worden
was ich nicht gehört habe wäre eine
Planungsvariante für den Fall dass die
420 Millionen nicht zusammenkommen durch
private Investoren es gibt also
offensichtlich keine ich sag mal
abgespckte Version des Ganzen nur ganz
oder gar nicht habe ich das richtig
verstanden ganz oder gar nicht es kann
nur das gesamte Projekt sein ganz oder
gar nicht wenn wir nur die Hälfte machen
gibt das Projekt um weil dann die
Synergien fehlen das ganze Projekt kommt
so und nicht anders ich kann Ihnen
versprechen mit all meiner Kraft werde
ich mich einsetzen das ganze dann auch
zu realisieren aber nicht so wie es in
einem Leserbrief gestanden hat um mir
ein Denkmal zu setzen meine Damen und
Herren sondern einzig und allein
deswegen weil ich meiner Verantwortung
gegenüber der Bevölkerung unserer Stadt
gerecht werden möchte helfen Sie mit
dabei d un das gelingt
[Applaus]
herzlich einfach klasse sind stolz auf
unser
Bürgermeister no noch
noch
[Musik]
schafft ihr das schafft ihr das
ja nur
bis viel m sehen funktioniert das ist
Julian geht heute mal mit M ein bisschen
einweisen und einfach erklären abhacken
richtig und unten weg alles klar okay
tschüss
[Musik]
seit Juli
2005 bin ich
betriebsleiter
ja mein Großvater ist hierher gekommen
schlesig Holstein aus Friesland hierher
gekommen hat mein Großvater Betrieb
geleitet und dann hat mein Vater das
übernommen und bin ich in der dritten
Generation jetzt ich Ken die Landschaft
ja schon seit weiß nicht le schon 30
Jahre hier und das ist schon Privileg
hier arbeiten zu dürfen das muss ich
einfach so sehen weil erstmal ist es
mich Privileg weil ich aufgewachsen bin
und
dann in der Heimat zätig zu sein das
fine ich schon ganz okay und vor allem
hier in dieser Landschaft
ähm sie finde ich schon ziemlich
klasse eigentlich hatte ich mir
vorgestellt nicht hier die Tür zuumachen
aber wenn es nicht anders geht dann ist
es halt so n dann muss man muss ich halt
überlegen wie es weiter geht
ne
so jetzt gehen wir in unser beröhchen
MSS mal was tun hier ist ja
Montag neue Woche
beginnt neuen Themen das Wort probleme
gibt's bei uns nicht gibt nur viele
Themen die es abzuarbeiten gilt keine
Probleme wir sammeln Projekte und das
fällt uns wahnsinnig leicht weil wir uns
auf ein Thema derart spezialisiert haben
auf Hotels und
dass wir auf dieser kleinen Marktnische
uns nicht nur Namen gemacht haben
sondern wir stellen fest wir sind fast
alleine auf der Welt mit diesem
Spezialthema morgen Frau
Laris alles
okayes gehen mal gleich die Liste durch
können Sie mal gucken ob sie Mohammed og
geil Abu Dhabi erreichen Mohammed og
geil ich glaube 24 Ländern sind wir
zurzeit tätig in vier
Kontinenten ich genau der Zeit wo du in
München bist da schiebe ich hier die die
kairoprjekte noch mal rein hier genau in
der Zeit ah ja die sind wir sind soweit
fertig ich muss das noch durchgucken
alles m die ganze Planung noch einmal
wenn und noch ein paar Korrekturen
machen ohne manag das alles immer ganz
toll am Computer was ich ja gar nicht
könnte ich weiß noch nicht mal wie ein
Computer an und ausgeschaltet wird also
hier so ein schöner Balkenplan da sehe
ich genau wann ich wohin muss das sind
ja riesige
millionenpjekte wir haben mal bei 2
Millionen angefangen die ersten Projekte
8 Millionen war ein riesen Projekt für
uns dann 50 Millionen wir sind
angekommen bei Projekten von über 400
450 Millionen du mitnehmen musst um den
Johnny von den zu treffen ich habe
gesehen Du h die Rechnung mir rausgelegt
habe ich die ist die noch nicht bezahlt
also fangen mit dem Geld mal an denn der
Laden muss ja hier funktionieren wir
haben ja immense Lohnzahlungen jeden
Monat
sind die beide noch nicht bezahlt Muskat
sulterat vonom nicht
bezahlt ja das geht ein Projekt zwei
zwei Projekte eins in masket Oman der
Hauptstadt vom Sultanat von Oman ein ein
Bankgebäude hab das Modell hier hier
steht so wunderschönes Projekt es ging
um dieses Gebäude hier Geschosse ein
Bankgebäude deutsche banksoll rein im
Ganzen geht glaube ich um
155000 ne 155000 und diese erste
Anzahlung obwohl die Leistung schon weit
mehr erbracht ist zahlen wir
nicht aber das ist zum Glück die
Ausnahme also wir haben ja wir haben 18
wir haben gestern mal aufgelistet wie
viel arabische Projekte haben wir 18 18
Projekte in der arabischen Welt davon
würde ich
sagen tja das ist unsere Diskussion
zahlen viele pünktlich nicht alle nicht
alle nicht alle aber ich sage am Ende
werden sie alle zahlen weil sie alle
begeistert sind von unseren Dingen er
der beste akquisiteur den ich je
kennengelernt habe so haben wir
wahnsinnig viel zu tun und ich habe hier
viel zu tun um all das zu managen mit
unserem Team und auf die Wege zu bringen
ich betreibe hier die Höhle und sehe zu
dass das Feuer schön brennt und er geht
draußen auf die Jagd mit feilen Bogen
und akquiriert dann alles also super
klasse das ist überhaupt nicht mein Ding
also die ganzen Entwürfe das sind ja
ganze Stadt mit 20 großen Projekten und
400 Gebäuden diese ganzen Entwürfe die
ganzen hochbauentwürfe leitet Frau Bohne
mit ihrem Team ich verkaufe sie
quasi na hier sind so meine meine
Projekte an den ich tagsüber arbeite
also hier das Beispiel das ist im
Sultanat von Oman das die neue Botschaft
die neue Botschaft in Cairo the wave die
Woge in um das nördlich von Dubai das
noch mal Dubai so geht das hier we alles
uns
Projekte hier ist die königliche Familie
das S immer genau Bescheid wissen V die
Royal Family dass wir wissen wel mit
welchem schich haben wir es jetzt gerade
zu
tun das ist hier der schichmdum der die
vielen Pferde sammelt den wir für
bberbeck uns ausdenken ne der hat 20.000
Pferde
ja so mit der Musik g mit der Musik das
läuft so so irgendwas besonderes
zu super Stimmung Aufbruch in
auf dies 70 kriegen oder ja let mal hat
ich bei der dir ich 73 ich wer mit 54 55
zufrieden besonderes
Problem og das Pick ich aber hinterher
ne gut ja dann machen wir
das schnell machen sonst müssen Sie
nämlich
freue mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jaitte
für mich und für die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in der Landesregierung die
damit arbeiten ist das Projekt bberbeck
über das sie hier
reden wieder ein solcher fast
symbolischer Punkt wenn jetzt
internationale Unternehmen herkommen und
das ganze Projekt HT ausschließlich
davon ab die Hunderte von Millionen Euro
bereit sind in die Hand zu nehmen
und zu sagen wir trauen uns zu das hier
zu entwickeln und da muss einen geben
der hat ein bisschen Geld da muss andere
geben die geben viele Kredite und das
müssen andere wieder besichern da sind
viele weltweit dabei wenn man hunderte
von Millionen investiert die gucken
spinnt da einer oder hat eine gute Idee
aber meine Damen und Herren es ist etwas
was nicht ein paar Leute mal im Traum
sich ausgedacht haben sondern ist ein
sehr sehr konkretes Konzept mit sehr
guten Erklärung warum hier wiederum in
der Mitte Deutschlands nicht in der
Peripherie sondern Mitte Deutschland wo
Menschen aus dem Ruhrgebiet und Menschen
aus dem Frankfurter Raum und Menschen
aus dem Hannoveraner Raum und sogar
Menschen aus dem Berliner Raum aus
vielen Ecken den Schnittpunkt finden
können herrliche Landschaft in einer
unberührten Weise vorzufinden in die man
mit Behutsamkeit und der Aufnahme von
alten Traditionen ein moderne Landschaft
für Erholung und Sport und Freizeit
hineinsetzen kann das ist der Durchbruch
im Tourismus das ist eine neue Qualität
nordestens über das was wir bisher
heraush haben und das schau sie
Bürgermeister zu verdanken und das ist
ein verdammt wichtiger Schritt verdammt
wichtiger
[Applaus]
Schritt Recht und Freiheit
s
rües
g
dieses
es
für deutes
[Musik]
Vaterland sch
lies
glükesü
dees
[Musik]
vatland
okay hat denn sonst irgendeiner an
diesem Protokoll etwas zu
meckern also es gibt genau den
Sachverhalt des Gespräches wieder schön
zum ersten zum zweiten zum Dr
angenommen Top 3 Zusammenfassung
weiterer Vorgehensweise Sicherung des
Grundstückes a
und ohne Grundstück ohne Schloss
Beberbeck Domäne kein
Projekt wir haben Deadline oder ein
Scheideweg des Objektes zum positiven
wie negativen gefunden der etwa im Jahr
2007 liegt
Ende
2007 jetzt mag das zwar 15 16 Monate
weit ins Land sein aber bei einer
objektentwicklung die dieser Größen
Ordnung ist das eigentlich schon über
morgen mus mal festhalten die Monate
verfliegen auch diese fün Monate bis zum
sogenannten Scheideweg werden im Zuge
verfliegen wir sind ja jetzt schon seit
November dabei über diese
grundstückssicherung konkret
nachzudenken also ein halbes Jahr wir
müssen jetzt irgendwie und des haben
auch diese riee von Anwälten und Notaren
die heute juristischen Beirat hier an
unserer Seite sitzen wir müssen heute
konkrete Beschlüsse fassen wie wir jetzt
step für step und mit Terminvorgabe
jetzt endlich dieses leidvolle Thema vom
Tisch kriegen jetzt müssen wir uns die
Frage stellen brauchen wir das
Grundstück um die Entwicklung
vorantreiben zu können oder können wir
die Entwicklung auch ohne dass wir
physisch dieses Grundstück in den Händen
halten seites der Stadthof geism vorand
das ist eigentlich die Kernfrage die wir
uns beantworten müssen für den heutigen
Tag um es noch mal zu visualisieren
würde ich gerne noch mal an die Tafel
malen und dann können wir noch mal
glaube ich in großer Runde diskutieren
haben eine B vor zeig eine Kernfrage
stellt brauchen wir das Grundstück ich
hatte ja gerade gesagt wir brauchen
unbedingt das machen wir nicht weiter
wir wertsteig das Grundstück mit jeder
Sitzung wenn ich diese Tagessätze hier
sehe jeder 1000000000 die Sitzung ist 20
000 Wert mindestens wir steigern mit
jedem Tag wo wir an dem Projekt arbeiten
die wertialtigkeit dieses Grundstücks
das Land Hessen sitzt eigentlich zurück
und wartet macht mal schön weiter und
fragt immer noch wie weit seid ihr
eigentlich und deswegen sage ich ich
stoppe das wirklich bewusst hier wenn
wir nicht endlich zu einer
grundstückssicherung kommen sollten wir
diese F gar nicht mehr führen hier das
ist provokativ aber es trifft im Punkt
der sagt eben es geht n der eine Weg der
zeig als König wir haben aber auch in
der Vergangenheit auch schon mal
diskutiert dass es doch durchaus und ich
musste ja auch hier als als als kleiner
Bürgermeister musste ich ja auch die
Terminologie erstmal verinnerlichen
davon gesprochen es gibt auch Venture
Capital ich habe dann ich wusste gar
nicht was das war so Venture Capital
dann habe ich dann formuliert ich sagt
lieber Adventure capital dann kommen
ganze Sache schon mal ein bisschen näher
und ich habe heute morgen eigentlich
gedacht der Peter Breuer der wird jetzt
hier so eine
Powerpoint Präsentation uns bringen und
wird dann sagen oder wer auch immer hier
am Tische komm her die 1 Million oder
die 2 Millionen je nachdem da habe ich
den XY oder da habe ich die oder jene
Bank die würden euch zu Hilfe eilen und
würden das ganze dann finanzieren das W
doch auch ein Weg also für mich als
Projektentwickler sage ich wir brauchen
das Grundstück
ich möchte dieses zarte damit wir hier
vielleicht Z ein Punkt kommen dieses
zarte pilchen hier von Rechtsanwalt Dr
Meininger vielleicht etwas deutlicher
machen ich würde das so darstellen her
dr Meininger so einen dicken Pfeil lass
uns endlich endlich das Grundstück von
nach von da nach hier holen endlich es
geht nicht anders es geht einfach nicht
anders und das sollten wir jetzt endlich
machen wir sollten jetzt beschließen das
ist so das tun wir und sollten jetzt uns
gut vorbereiten und in zwei Wochen nach
wiesbahn gehen um denen zu sagen und zu
signalisieren wir kommen das faste
Drohung wir kommen wir müssen angreifen
die soll das Grundstück gefä
[Musik]
rausrücken
so
aber es geht gerade nicht so gut ich
rufe die nachher zurück ja ich bleibe
bis Mittwoch in Moskau und dann kommen
die
schelenen also die nächste Frage passt
kein
lchplatz ja ich ruf ich ruf ich ruf
Peter mal an ja es ist schreckig
Ciao eine
verhrerin eine Verehrerin hat man ja
auch noch ab zu mal aber keine Zeit für
dieser dieser Job verlangt 7 Tage s Tage
die
Woche sie Tage 365 Tage kein Weihnachten
kein Ostern kein Pfingsten W nicht mal
Karneval und das alles reinländer kein
Karneval Zettel
[Musik]
dringelassen
ja der Herr grot ja ich
verbinde
satler hallo Herr satler hallo Herr grot
ich grüße Sie sie haben mir gestern
Abend auf die m gesprochen ich hatte
Bürgerversammlung deswegen musste ich
sie wegdrücken völlig in Ordnung bitte
um verständnis ja natürlich
selbstverständlich ich habe letzte Woche
Freitag mit dr arnoldd gesprochen und
hab gestern mich auch noch mal mit kkuni
und Herrn Marsberg v
wirtschaftsor
Problem hier ist ich sag mal so ich
krieg den Arnold und den Weimer kriege
ich im Augenblick nicht dazu einen
Kaufvertrag zu unterschreiben ja nur wir
wollen dem Herrn satler solange er das
Ding nicht unter Dach und fachrad
nicht in eine Situation bringen dass er
plötzlich 8 Millionen auf dem Tisch
legen muss und das ganze und nachher
läuft das Ganze nicht und dann ist dann
habe ich dann habe ich das Herr grot
dann habe ich das Land für 8 Millionen
damit würde ich auch
wegrennen Herr grot also wir hatten ja
fürchterliche bange dass wir an an
zwischenfinanzierer und endfinanzierer
gar nicht dran kommmen das hat sich
mittlerweile entspannt und ich kann
Ihnen sagen wir haben nächste Woche ein
riesen Meeting mit dem Vorstand von
Bilfinger und Berger ja so und die
steigen ein und mit denen habe ich frore
Woche in München zusammengesessen bei
der EXPO REAL Herr grot dann wissen Sie
Bescheid dass wir also auf guten Wege
sindur noch mal zum Abschluss ah ja
dieses äh also die Vorlage jetzt soll
jetzt nicht weiterentwickelt werden oder
wie was soll das wir haben ja hier eine
Vorlage bekommen vom vom wirtschaftsrort
ein Brief Entwurf
als weiterer Baustein also Meilenstein
also unter anderem die ganzen
Geschichten als weiterer Meilenstein
wird der Verkauf der dominenfläch in
Form eines Kaufvertrags mit
aufschiebener Bedingung vorbereitet aber
da sagt natürlich unsere Juristen hier
sofort ja das ist aber ein ganz anderer
neuer Punkt in dem Moment und da müsste
man überlegen ob man nicht wieder ins
Kabinett muss weil man dann wenn man
jetzt den Notar unterschreibt hat man ja
quasi ist man ja
da doch schon ein wesentlichen Schritt
weitergegangen ja ja wollen wir oder
wollen wir doch also Hop oder top
irgendwann muss jetzt mal wir können er
unterschreiben wenn es wenn uns klar
sauber vorgelichtt wird auch mit ein
bisschen mit Hintergrund was da
passieren richtig richtig kriegen das
hin okay ja gut wenn nicht dann komme
ich trotzdem mal daunter dann wir beiden
uns mal zusammen ja okay schönen Dank
tschüss ch das sind schwerfällige K ich
sage ich sage es istmer die die die die
machen vor Angst in der Hose Gürtel um
Hosenträger Hut auf damit ja nichts
passieren kann da könnt irre werden wenn
wir alle so schon gearbeitet hätten in
der Zeit da wären wir noch keinen
Schritt
voran das sind nicht die Minister oder
sonst irgendwas die gesamte
Administration Herr Stern wenn Sie die
nicht hinter sich haben dann verlieren
sie jeden Krieg die machen ihn alles
kaputt die machen alles
kaputt so zeig mir mal den Plan wo ist
denn jetzt eigentlich unsere
Seebühne wo ist diebühne da se da auf
der Seite da da wo die sind da kommt die
Seebühne hin und da dann die
Promenade und da oben können wir uns das
Künstlerdorf vorstellen man muss es
ihben klar machen was mit den
Himmelsrichtungen hier ist wir können
nicht das Hotel rein nach Norden
ausrichten dann liegen alle Terrassen
zwar mit dem schönen Blick zum See aber
alle im Norden alle im Schlagschatten
das sollten wir vermeiden und
vorschlagen dass wir ganz oben hochgehen
dann haben wir den Blick über diese
Straßen Schneise hier
runter
das hatte ich auch skizziert schon mal
das hervorragend auch mit der Anwendung
von wellnis und sowas ah ja wellnis DF
man nicht vergessen ist das unser
Bürgermeister ja
ja ist der Klasse unser geliebter
Bürgermeister der Stadt chwaler ein
erfolgreich der Bürgermeister von Nord
fahen ich GLB der 72% bei der letzten
ltagsfah
gekregt Rudi du siehst ich habe extra
den roten Schal angeen gut ja
Ex sei gegrüßt sei gegrüßt komm ganz
technische Frage wie groß ist die Fläche
von dem gerade noch mal 100 Hektar
wirklich ja wow der war ja mal doppelt
so groß geplant 100 he ja men jetzt ist
aber hen satler wiissen neidisch Herr
Bürgermeister wir wollen sie heute
verdamm verdonnern zu einer tollen
Entscheidung g hier mit mit Zeugen hier
schauen mich jetzt mal in diese Richtung
jetzt mssen wir be bringen
Bürgermeister das wird schwer sein also
man möge sich vorstellen da oben das
Hotel für die Sportler ja für die
Leichtathletik Fußballer bisschen
Maritim Sport natürlich das
reiterzentrum nicht was wir auch
unbedingt haben möchtest und Golf
dahinter noch Golf vor also ein großes
großes
Sporthotel man kann sich das noch nicht
so vorstellen also wir als visionäre
wissen schon ganz genau so 3 4 5 s
Geschosse hoch
aber damit wir das H schon zeigen können
hier Moment also den Plan hten wir schon
mal vor langer Zeit den kennst du nicht
den K aber der ist so schön bunt ne und
hier kann man sein das ist also Romantik
sage ich mal natürlich s nicht die
Situation ist ja viel schöner weil es
hier weg aufgeht hier geht das ja in
vielen vielen Etagen mehr so wie am
Mittelmeer das wird ein Knaller hier ne
an solchen Tagen wie heute wä das super
für eschwealer wenn man in 5 Minuten aus
der Stadt hier wäre und hier ein ein
wellnisag oder wellnisstunden verbringen
könnte aber auch wieder gemanaged vom
Hotel und jetzt brauchen wir ein
Verbindungsglied dazwischen da haben wir
an ein
Künstlerdorf gedacht was wir integrieren
artist
villagestorf Kunst oder Kultur wir
können es auch Kulturdorf nennen alles
weil das Spektrum größer ist weil wir
dann die Musik noch mit reinbekommen
dass man dann an ein Magnet schafft auch
für die ganze Region dass ist hier das
chweiler
Künstlerdorf
ich habe heute Nacht sehr sehr schlecht
geschlafen ganz wenig geschlafen weil
ich permanent aufgewacht bin und dann
ist mir das Ganze durch den Kopf
gegangen und hab mir dann auch die Frage
gestellt ist das richtig was du jetzt
machst dass du jetzt hier so Druck
machst aber ich bin überzeugt davon im
Sinne der Sache muss jetzt mal was
passieren das sind
Scheißdinger das wird also dann primär
so sein dass wir mit Tom kause und
cornelus Obier uns zunächst einmal
darüber unterhalten müssen wie es denn
weitergehen soll mit uns denn die todos
die verabritet werden die werden nicht
eingehalten
und es wird nichts geliefert Tom Krause
und die dazu ihm stoßenden als
Projektentwicklungsgesellschaft die
wollten sich die Gesellschaft da
aufstellen wollten kommandisten außen
rum bringen das hat wir alles verredet
aber das ist bis heute nichts passiert
so da stehe ich permanent an der
Front und muss dann was erzählen und
wenn ich dann der W erzählen würde was
dann in den privatenektor passiert W sie
sagen oh J bisschen bescheuert hier geht
nicht die
geht Hose aber das machen wir
untereinander jetzt aus nach draußen
dringen sollte das
[Musik]
nicht
ich weiß noch wie wie wie ich mit dem
Tom erste mal frühstücken
Braig und das ganze dann begonnen hat
haben uns gefreut über die Formulierung
wir züchten das blaue Pferd was
überhaupt noch keine Socke hat und
deswegen will das jeder sehen und
deswegen wird das klappen da Drau und
alles was wir bis jetzt ja gemeinsam
gemacht haben das war ja auch
Schaft die das Projekt wird immer
dramatischerön
essenhäig we da Unterschied Meinung gibt
darüber werden wir heute
diskutieren es wird heute möglicherweise
heftig
ich ahne es es knistert in der
Luft ich mache wirklich kein he draus
ich bin sehr sehr unzufrieden ich bin
enttäuscht über das was bis jetzt
vorliegt und ich glaube wir sind heute
an dem Punkt angekommen wo wir endlich
jetzt mal nicht neur Mund Spitzen
sondern wo wir mal pfeifen müssen lass
uns ruhig mal aus der Tagesordnung jetzt
rausgehen denn das was wir jetzt
diskutieren da steht par prototo
da steht pas prototo und das ist unser
Problem seit anderthalb Jahren wir hat
Nut auf wer bringt es wer bringt jenes
hüpfen wir seit über einem Jahr hüpfen
wir da schon
hinterher und liegen heute Businesspläne
vor ich frag jetzt noch mal so das
müsste Protokoll dann stehen intern
intern intern intern haben wir haben so
ein Konzept schonestehen müssen wir gar
nicht agieren können intern haben wir
sie nur nicht offiziell also wir können
Sie auf Tisch legen
ja ich glaube nicht aber wir sind jetzt
an dem Punkt ich glaube
nicht auch die gr oder Feinplanung zu
eurer Gründung PEG dass man jetzt sagen
könnte jawoll hier das ist eine
Vertragsgrundlage da setzen wir jetzt NN
ein oder so oder so können wir da
stricken ich habe davon noch nichts
gesehen es gibt auch noch kein Vertrag
zwischen der Stadt oder Vertragsentwurf
zwischen der Stadt und der noch zu
gründenden PG der Vertrag ist ja genauso
wichtig warte ich drauf
ist eine Bringschuld von wem von euch
von uns ja WoEn wir das beschlossen ja
aber wir sind doch noch keinen Schritt
vorangekommen ja K auch nicht bin ich
den haben Grundstück habencht Tom da
kannst Du Dich jetzt nicht mehr hinter
verschanzen ich habe das Grundstück und
ich habe das Planungsrecht das kann ich
dir sagen ein Jahr weiter wir kommen
nicht von der Stelle und wenn ich jetzt
mal sagen darf was wir als Tod
vereinbart haben und was die öffentliche
Seite sprich jetzt mal die Stadt auf
Geis und wir haben machen soll mhm da
habe ich ein ganz ganz reines Gewissen
da haben wir blitze blank
gearbeitet wenn du sagst hoch tief hat
von euch Papiere bekommen Wiemer so eine
PG wie ihr euch das vorstellt Bilfinger
Berger hätte diese Papiere auch m ne
haben diese Papiere auch mm da steht ja
der hammut und so weiter die haben die
seit sech Wochen seit sechs
Wochen und jetzt eine Frage ja und warum
haben wir sie nicht auch lass mich noch
mal sehr potiert meine Position meine
Wahrnehmung formulieren ich glaube nicht
dass dieses Papier was hier an
derwartungshaltung da ist tatsächlich
bei Bilfinger und Berger vorlegt weil
ich wüsste nicht wer das erarbeitet
haben soll ich Ken es nicht ich Ken es
auch nicht ich glaube wir haben es nicht
was wir haben ist eine mehrseitige
Auflistung in der die die Schritte die
in der nächsten die drei nächsten Phasen
der projektckung passieren m ü
niedergeschrieben sind und eine eine gr
Anforderungsprofil ja genau ein
anfüungsprofil was erledigt werden muss
was diese
projekteentwicklungsgesellschaft
sicherlich als Aufgabe ich bin schon
sehr sehr langmütig und auch sehr sehr
geduldig aber das ist irgendwann
einmal soweit dass ich dann sage Freunde
dann müssen wir uns irgendwie anders
aufstellen dann müssen so das ist jetzt
mehrfach rüber gekommen Herr
Bürgermeister möchte ich darauf mal
antworten stellen müssen wissen was das
sag ich mal sie damit du jetzt den
Unterschied merkst ich kann mich
erinnern dass wir prom kusebohne in
einer bestimmten Phase dieser
projentwicklung gebeten worden sind
bitte macht uns nicht nur die Broschüre
präsentiert sie großartig und dann
verabschiede ich euch bitte bleibt dabei
übernehmt mit Verantwortung überzeugt
auch weiterhin Betreiber Investoren und
Politik bleibt da i aber wenn ich das
heute mitkriege dann möchte ich fast
seine Worte mit aufgreifen dann können
wir die Sitzung in 10 Minuten beenden
dann bin ich weg ich muss sowieso nach
Amsterdam heute ich muss hier nicht
beibleleiben für mich dieses Projekt
nicht existentiell überhaupt nicht es
ist nice dabei zu sein aber es ist nicht
notwendig für mich und wenn ich sehe
dass das immerine Qual ist und dass hier
dass ich hier mit Vorwürfen hier
überhäuft werde seit ein halben Stunde
redest du so lieber Henner dann sag ich
mir das tue ich mir nicht an das tu ich
mir einfach nicht an denn ich habe hier
reichlich Engagement reingebracht jede
Sitzung ist für mich ist für mich ist
für mich zeitaufwendig ja sehr
zeitaufwendig ich bereit mich auch immer
gut auf diese Sitzungen vor und ich bin
heute sogar mal pünktlich gewesen sehr
pünktlich ja und ich habe dieses
Gespräch jetzt hier dieses Gespräch mit
bilfm Berger was am 7 stattfindet das
hält uns ja letztendlich auf wenn das ja
nicht wäre so wichtig das ist würden wir
ja wahrscheinlich schon weiter
gearbeitet haben aber alles wartet jetzt
auf ne ist war es ist war am 17 haben
wir ja eigentlich sehr viel besprochen
nur jetzt wartet alles auf den großen
politischen Termin vor Ort
wahrscheinlich wird es dann leider
rechnen am 7
wahrscheinlich das heißt wir warten
jetzt alle auf diesen lass mich jetzt
bitte Ausreden wir warten jetzt alle auf
diesen großen politischen Tag Vorort
[Gelächter]
jainer aber die angelegt nicht nein ich
möchte mit Herrn grause und mit Herrn
Obier heute morgen bisschen Neugier ein
bisschen Geschmack an ganzen sind schon
auf
we die müssen heute nicht zu uns
sein bsteller klingt ein bisschen hart
aber die wollen Auftrag generieren ein
Auftrag besorgen 360 Millionen und 10%
ist Gewinn das heißt 36 Millionen machen
die Gewinn sch mal ein bisschen langsam
fahren werden dann das Schloss sehen
fahren dann hier durch und werden dann
diese Allee hochfahren bis dort oben wo
der Kuhstall sich befindet ja no mal
vorweg von hier vom Marktplatz bis da
obenin das sind 2,2 km unglaublich es
ist unglaublich und es ist eine ganz
ganz tolle
Sache das hier oben
ist sogenann bergolat der geht dann bis
hinten hin und
schön bis zu den
Wildschweinen nochesser noch besser bis
Wald junges Wind hier ja ja die sind
also auch in der Zuchtleistung sind die
ervorragend ne ja ich darf mal ihren
Blick lenken hier auf den
Ortsteil weberbeck auf das Dorf sie
sehen hier diese Mulde das wird
sicherlich profiliert werden und D es
geht ja um die großen Seenplatten wir
werden insgesamt 34 da sehen bauen um
weitere Attraktionen in die Landschaft
zu bringen wenn man jetzt in Richtung
Scheune guckt dann sehen sie so ein
leichte Erhebung
das das ist ja die Insel wo nachher die
Clubanlage also sowas wie Club Robinson
Club militerrane hinkommt die Linke
Halle könnte ich mir vorstellen das wird
die Eventhalle von Klub Robinson wo Jen
am Theater stattfindet und rechts das
gourm Restaurant für 400
Gäste
schon man zeht schon möchte die
Fantasie ja schon einzigartig also große
Aufgabe V sich
hierieren gemeinsam gemeinsam wir wollen
mal schauen W
gemeinsam das SP auch an so inen drin
spürst du
das wir packen das
hier
ja hier haben wir das Schloss wie viel
Leute sind jetzt hier untergebracht
43 43 und die haben eigentlich ein
Vertrag noch über 17 Jahre 18 Jahre aber
wir haben ein sehr gutes Verhältnis auch
an der Stelle in in der Stadt und wie
ich das vorhin schon gesagt habe das
kriegen wir wirklich ganz elegant ganz
elegant und
geräuschlos und das ist der Herr Berner
das ist der Scham der kleinen Stadt da
kennt man sich Ding Flaschen Wein wo
andere lange Briefe schreiben
müsen haben zusammen handbespiel der
geschäftsfü ich s zus so hab dann haben
wir zwei ab haben gebraucht dann hat wir
ausgehext und es wird habt ihr schon
drüber erzählt von der Dimension Tom
dass hier der Flügel erweitert wird bis
zu dem getreidespeich gerade erklären
jetzt hast du mir die Pote weggenommen
ich wollte mich mal einmal als Schloss
herfühlen
Schloss geft das gefällt mir einmal vor
Publikum Schloss
her also dieses Schloss wird dreimal
größer als jetzt ist hier passen zur
Zeit 43 am Ende mal 150 Zimmer viel
Gastronomie Restaurants fünf Stern Hotel
hier der
wellesbereich und dort die Konferenz
facilities und dann gegenüber
spiegelbildlich da sehen wir jetzt auch
schon das historische offiziantenhaus
mit so klein Laternen oben diese
laterern wird ausgebaut als als Site als
mesonett für zwei Ebenen für den
Bürgermeister und das wird dann der
innenliegende
Schlosspark zum Wandeln zum Amüsieren
zum Kennenlernen
Kommunikation die Jungen haben die haben
Geschmack mach du das die haben die
haben
geschmackul wasserm
aus dieser
Quelle es gibt ein besonderes hchen und
diese veredelungsanlage die haben wir
gestern angezapft haben gedt
Wurst probieren und dann anschließend
den Schnaps das was ich auch vorhin
erzählt habe mit den Firmen die uns
operieren also ich war durch zufällig
zuostern im Roman und hab mir dort neue
anl
ckt die besteht auch immerhin aus vier
Hotels an der perlschnur und das Geld
ist da dafür also es gibt Leute die
haben genug Geld man muss s nur
finden
okayes sehr gefreut auf denke mal auf
eine gute Zukunft ja gegenseitig an bin
überzeugt davon dass man gemeinsam unser
Ziel geh ja ja genau dann schauen wir
[Musik]
weiter
č
[Musik]
in dem Moment in dem wir uns jetzt
befinden können wir nicht erwarten dass
die Investoren und Betreiber in Scharen
bei uns Schlange stehen das wird so
kommen davon sind wir überzeugt und
deswegen müssen wir dorthin wo die
Investoren sind die kommen nicht zu uns
sondern wir müssen zu Ihnen und das ist
jetzt eben der Weg nach kann bzw nach
[Musik]
nzza
erklären wir sind also auf der Seite ein
bisschen an dem nordang und
gegenüberliegen sehen Sie die
mittelalterlichen
Ortschaften hinten links
faance das ist alles
[Musik]
integriert wir hab mal versucht wirklich
minimal
inversiv ja einzugreifen denn die Natur
hat ja für uns einen eigenen Wert das
ist doch was es ausmacht
genau ist einer der wenigen Stellen wo
wir eingegriffen haben dann weil die
beiden golfbahnlagen so nah da geht eine
dann hoch dass das halt alles weg war
und D haben
nachgeplant das ist keine dision die
präsidentened die präsidentened ist
natürlich wie der Name vom huten
lässt die
hochwertigste Möglichkeit bei uns zu
wohnen was kostet dieal
die kostet knapp 10 000 €
9000 das sind die Wohnbereiche auf der
anderen Seite gegenüberliegen befinden
sich die
schlafräumlichkeitön GU zu Thema
Sicherheit hier Verbindung Golfplatz zur
privaten Bewohnung da ich nur Geschmack
ja soll sein Appetit an
reger das ist immer ein ganz sensibles
aufeinandertreffen und das muss man
spüren da muss man Feeling für
entwickeln und das haben wir glaube ich
auch sonst wären wir nicht so weit
gekommen auf der anderen Seite bin ich
auch sage ich ganz offen ein bisschen
aufgeregt denn diese Begegnung gerade
beim ersten Mal ja die hat man nicht
sehr oft die Chance mit so
herausragenden Persönlichkeiten in
Kontakt zu kommen und dann überlegt man
schon mal morgens früh munter wird jung
wenn du das jetzt versägst und wenn du
da nicht höllisch aufpasst dann ist eine
Chance vorbei und die dann noch mal
wiederkommt das ist dann
fraglich wenn unser Land was braucht
dann ist es schon ein Stück weit diesen
dieser dieser dieser Spirit auf Höhe
riesiken eingehen Visionär zu sein
riskanter zu sein und nicht diese
Allianz versicherungsmentalität das was
man hat nmer zu riskieren und und und da
mangelt bei unserem Land in unserem Land
eher und deswegen ich wegen finde ich
das beachtlich was sie machen dass man
da einfach mit mit so einem Pioniergeist
und mit so einem mit so einem Geist wo
man nicht nur bisschen Grenzen
verschiebt sondern wo wir strukturbrüche
macht und wo man sagt und jetzt machen
wir hier was visionäres was Großes das
finde ich einfach begeisterungswürdig
und und und finde ich
jetzt mental und in der Art und Weise W
uns hier jetzt begegnet sind einfach
unterstützungsfä einal aber nicht bei
uns in
Teil
irg
[Musik]
könnte die zweit letzte Ernte hier sein
oder könnte theoretisch kann sein
ja mich wundert schon dass man hier eine
Golfplätze plant ohne Ende fünf Stück
oder wie viel und
äh wo man hier dann die Golfplätze hat
die überhaupt nicht laufen ich bin auch
gegen weil ich dagegen bin dass man so
eine Kulturlandschaft
zerstört
vor allem finde ich zu bombastisch und
und wenn ich alleine sehe was an
Lohnkosten und Unterhaltungskosten auf
so ein Unternehmen
zukommt ist enorm also ich weiß nicht
wie man das muss das muss erst mal
reinkommen bevor man an Gewinne
denkt
und
ähm
t ich halte es nicht für
realistisch
ich brauch jetzt heute Abend die lass
mal drin die lass wir auch die BR ist
heute Abend das wä gut wenn das
Mitnehmen das Okay Schlüssel dem
vertraue ich den Schlüssel an könen Sie
auch mir geben danke schön bis
DAH ich um 18 Uhr wieder ja
Uhr
eigentlich möchte ich jetzt ein Bier
trinken Mund fuselig ich habe schon
drei hinter mir aber ich kann kein Bier
trinken weil ich gleich in die Botschaft
muss dann kann man keine bierfahen haben
der Botschaft ah ja ich habe ja meine
bundesdeutsche Krawatte mit ich kann
auch eine Fliege heute tragen die
Architekten tragen auch gerne Pflege mal
gucken ob ich die nicht heute mal
trage vorne
ist nicht so
einfach ja
Krause ja
ja ja ich komme ich hab ja 7
Uhr nein es fängt 7:30 Uhr an soll ich
in den Wagen vorfahren ja das W n
welches hat mE schönes a gekackt hier
das ist ja wirklich das
[Musik]
ist das ist alles im massiven Sandstein
gleichen wir haben den gleichen
Sandstein organisiert so 180 km von
Berlin in Richtung Süden hohen Zollern
Sandstein nennen wir den und aus diesem
Material ist vor was ich 250 Jahren oder
300 Jahren das Brandenburger Tor gebaut
worden und damit haben wir halt damals
ein europaweiten wettbewb gewonnen das
war ein Wettbewerb den haben wir
gewonnen mit dieser mit dieser
[Musik]
Idee
guck so
traurig Fr
[Musik]
mitgeb me jetzt hier hier schaut mal
hier das ist doch
wunderschön das Muster hier im Fußboden
sehr kompliziert gemacht dass das blaue
Marmor kommt aus Brasilien was komm für
architek ein sehr guter ein
williger kooperative auch
noch weil er hat also das entwickelt und
unser Wünschen entsprechend auch S weit
mitgemacht und sehr
geduldig2 die Fassade
entwickel der Botschafter dr
Hass
[Musik]
möch eine dappel nein
danke ja wir können es doch anfassen ja
oder nicht ja gib mir do mal deine Hand
nein das muss jetzt nicht
[Musik]
sein
Laptop
[Musik]
dai das ist
unserchall
[Musik]
Gerat you
so
ي
[Musik]
hab Falken Geschenk
gekriegt
kommst du bist Bürgermeister ich Tom
mein Bester ich grüße dich darf Dich
bekann
gehzt die schönen Damen dieser Welt die
schönen Damen dieser Welt begrüße ich
doch gerne guten Morgen oh ja das war
spät gestern ja Tom wir sind war es
heute: aber nicht auf Spaß sondern
wirklich Business bis 5:30 uh musst du
durchhalten auf der ETW so jetzt jetzt
wollen wir mal mal den Plan sehen hier
hinten ja bitte die Palme komm jetzt
jetzt erzäh mal hier
hier das ist hier das achte Weltwunder
und wir hatten unser erstes Projekt
genau hier genau in dieser Achse erstes
Hotel D sind wir nach hier gegangen und
dann nach hier und da war die kanlage
und da sind nach hier gegangen und jetzt
von da nach und ab
Di
K ab
DAV Palme ja an der Stelle hatten wir
ein K Projekt entwickelt das hat hier 50
Geschosse und das ist das Restaurant wen
Eck B guckst du 300 m
runter komm Set zu mir
ach was alles machen meine alten Knochen
[Musik]
hier ja ja
mus
gut date of F Date Date muss auch wo
haben wir den Kern
hin so lang dabei ne no ich kenne das
Land sprechen sie
deutsch
wo deponiert man
das
klein kchen nein ist doch keiner da ist
keiner
da so hier steigen wir aus dann gehen
wir hier durch und dann kommen wir hier
durch hier durch und der Bus der wird
dann hier wieder stehen ja und hier
steigen wir ein und dann fahren wir ZH
km hoch und das gibt ein firen
freizeitressort das dollste schönste
feinste eleganteste der
Republik
me so wir fahen
gut und schwarzrot
Gold Landes was hat ich die Frau was
Bohne so schick gemacht hat ichich ja
richtig geschmückt heute mein
lieblingsbürgermeister lass Dich lass
dich drücken Tom schön dass du da bist
du musst in deiner situativen Wendigkeit
paratstellen und dann auf Stichwort aus
der Kulisse eilen genau auch immer wir
das hinkriegen ne machen wir machen wir
wir sind eingespieltes Team wir sind
eingespieltes Team ja
hallo
Jael müssen s was mal hinkriegen wir
hauen das Datum raus wir hauen das Datum
raus wir nehmen das Datum raus vom 17.4
wenn wir die ganze Meldung rausnehmen da
fehlen uns drei Seiten dann bricht meine
ganze Mappe zusammen das ist keine
Seitenzahl mehr in Ordnung und das ist
ja auch aufeinander
aufgebaut
ich atme ganz
heftig ich atme ganz heftig dann wer ich
gar keine Presser mal rausgeben also ich
setze mich nicht eine ganze Nacht dahin
und bastle da dran rum und wir machen
eine logische Aufbau und also dann hätte
man das gestern schon mal ein bisschen
erzählen können V Apel gut ich nehme
noch
raus reißen raus und schmeißen Weg der
muss mir noch einmal
kommen das gibt's do
nicht das unmöglich
kann seine Pressemitteilung auch in
Haare schmüen aber das ist beim letzten
Mal schon so gewesen das sind die
oberklugscheißer und die meinen sie
wüssten alles was sie da irgendwo auf
der Welt aufgeschnappt
hätten und es Reg schon
wieder da kommt der Bus so
auf Mensch fährt ja bis vor der Haustür
hieristerent herzlich willkommen sehr
gut schön dass Sie da sind so wir haben
uns noch mal eine Minute ohne Regen grüß
Dich
mal erzählen zu deiner schönen
ja dann gibt mir mal bitte so ein Mikro
ja dann würde ich mich ein
bisschen ich vielleicht ein wenig als
Reisebegleiter jetzt betätigen die
Domäne Beberbeck ist gegründet worden
nicht als Domäne sondern als Gestüt und
als jagdch hier sehen Sie rechts eine
große Fläche das wird das reiterareal
werden mit trabbrennbahn und Polo
spielen hier diese feldholsinsel die wir
bestehen bleiben mancher wird Grinsen
bei dem Poloplatz aber es gibt nur zwei
in Deutschland gleich schauen wir auf
das Schloss Beberbeck dort sind im
Moment 43 altenpflegeplätze drin und
dort soll dann der fünf Sterne Bereich
sich
erstrecken ja bis dahin erstmal danke
schön
ja ich glaube das ist eine ganz
imposante Kulisse hier bei uns so in der
Öffentlichkeit sagt das nicht aber das
sind schwer Demenzkranke die kommum
wahrnehmen ob sie draßen im Wald sind
und auch die altenö ist ja froh wenn
diese Lösung gefunden ma in die Stadt
zurück oder was die auflösen und wir
wollen hier aus diesem Schloss das
Kernstück machen als fünf Sterne Areal
und es wird dort in diese Richtung
erweitert werden noch einige Meter dran
und auch hier wird ein Flügel angesetzt
werden bis über den Weg den wir gleich
befahren werden
hinaus ja ja ja ja der einzige der hier
muckt
das ist der ist der Verwalter der in der
dritten Generation jetzt hier ist ne der
DR Köhling der Vater und auch der Opa
die waren schon hier als Verwalter
und der ist der einzige der KNT alle
anderen freuen sich drauf gut ja was
bedeutet bberck für die Region ja für
viele war das Projekt bberbeck 400
Millionen Investition mehrere Hotels
mehrere Golfplätze eigentlich ein
Beispiel für Mythen und Märchen am
Anfang ich glaube ist ein großes
Verdienst der Region des Bürgermeisters
und alle die daran mitgewirkt haben dass
inzwischen die ersten Hotelunternehmen
jetzt sagen ja wir sind bereit einen
Letter of inent wie das in neudeutsch
heißt also eine verbindliche
Absichtserklärung abzugeben und ich habe
dazu zu sagen dass alles was das Land
tun kann ein Grundstück zur Verfügung
stellen an Verkehrsinvestitionen dazu
schaffen wird geschehen wir sind bereit
wenn das Projekt zustande kommt für die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur und die übrige
Infrastruktur die notwendigen
Aufwendungen zu übernehmen das sind über
30 Millionen Euro das an uns jedenfalls
eine solche Idee nicht scheidert und
dann sind die privaten Investoren am
Zug so Bürgermeister tschüss ich bin weg
ja okay her dank ja so weiter nächste
Runde nächste Runde okay bis dahin
ja er hüpft er hüpft da rein und er ist
jetzt erstmal
weg
ich habe ein ganz tolles Gefühl ich bin
mir sicher dass der sler zufrieden ist
denn ich glaube dass
wir voneinander eine ganz gute Witterung
aufgenommen haben also wir haben bis
jetzt ganz wunderbar harmonisch zusammen
gearbeitet und es ist eine unheimlich
angenehme Projekt Gruppe alle
Projektbeteiligten ziehen
ausgesprochen intensiv am selben
strangende und auch im Vergleich zu
anderen Projekten die wir schon
begleitet haben herrscht also eine
wirklich ganz fantastische
Konsensfähigkeit
hicker hallo Wecker
halloo Herrer gr geht gut gut schau aus
hier Danke zurück gut sieht's aus und
habt das mitgemacht was köerchen
voll und
jetzt um die
DVD ja ich bin so doof ich krieg Kasten
jetzt habe ich oh ja das ist die
Grundlage hier aus dem richtig aus dem
Prospekt ja und jetzt würde ich schon
mal sagen tolle DVD ne
deutscheion tolle DVD ja ich ich ich
spür es gerade zu dann müssten wir das
jetzt sicherlich auch mal uns angucken
darum
geht's starten lass drauf ich habe noch
nicht ist der nemann noch da du musst
den Ausgang
kommen
oder irgendeiner von IT Leuten noch
da lass es abholen Montag ich will es
nicht mehr haben hier den lassen mal
hängen hier weil der so schön aussieht
da muss ich sowas von an mich
halten jedes Mal Jes mal jedes Mal wie
oft ich dieses Erlebnis schon gehabt
habe und dann sagst du irgendwas dann
bist du noch der Dumme
Mann warum h so viel Geld aus da kriegst
du die beste Laune verdorben mit so
einem Scheißdreck hier so eine Haare
schneiden ist aber auch gut
so soll was gucken aber es ist wichtig
also schade wir haben jetzt den Ton nur
aus dem Laptop und das ist ein toller
Ton mit dem suprecher guck mal hier guck
mal hier Becker hier da haben wir ein
halbes Jahr drauf gewartet dass wir
diese Lautsprecher kriegen die haben aus
Korea oder aus China oder aus dem
Nordpol haben sie einfliegen lassen das
hat 17 000 Steine gekostet
und niemals wenn wir irgendwo sind hör
auf
die ganze Nummer zusammen jedes mal wenn
du irgendwas machen willst da musst it
holen da musst den sonnerabend holen
sonst Hack kaputt und schmeißt weg da
müss man sich dann weiß dass nicht hat
herrbecker jetzt fahren wir uns wieder
runter ich möchte mich jetzt wieder
freuen und wenn der Ton nicht so richtig
ist dann dann singen wir noch ein
bisschenzu Set dich
nee so
Abmarsch Schloss bberbck
[Musik]
Resort willkommen in einem wahren
Märchen kommen Sie mit auf eine Reise
tief ins Herz Europas genau in die Mitte
von Deutschland
umgeben von sanften Hügeln und schönsten
Wäldern wird hier ein märchenwah
gemacht eines der größten Ferien Resorts
Europas das Schloss bberbck
Resort bezaubernde Landschaft ehwürdige
Architektur ein sagenhaftes
Freizeitangebot vielfältigster Hotel
und alles im Herzen
Deutschlands Schloss bberbck Resort
willkommen in einem wahren
[Musik]
Märchen
gut ein bisschen die Hose hier Nummer
jetzt hier aber W schon hinkriegen in
unserer situativen
Wendigkeit
hallo
guten
Bürgermeister meine ser verhrten Damen
und Herren Regierungspräsident ich freue
mich dass ich sozusagen fast Stammgast
werde hier undter mülller war nur vor
wenigen Stunden hier beim Notar und hat
im Auftrag der hchen Landesregierung den
grundstücksveräußerungsvertrag mit der
Projektgesellschaft für das
Gesamtgelände domainne bberberg
unterschrieben so dass das was ich hier
habe ist ein schönes Objekt weil es ist
mit dem ordentlichen Siegel eines Notars
gesiegel der Kaufvertrag sass aus der
Sicht des Landes Hessen jetzt nichts
mehr entgegensteht dass die Gemeinde
dass die Projektgesellschaft mit jedem
potenziellen Vertragspartner
rechtsverbindliche Verträge abschließen
kann und damit wir einen denke ich
weiteren Schritt soweit wir haben
beinflussen können in die Richtung sind
das
Projekt Wirklichkeit werden zu
lassen kleines bisschen nach rechts noch
kleines bisschen na rechts
ja danke das war es gibt schon kann ich
sagen es gibt schon
in Investoren die Interesse haben in
dieses Projekt einzusteigen richtig die
haben schon den Kopf ein bisschen zum
Fenster rausgestreckt nur Kapital ist
wie
so könn formulieren aber wir sind auf
guten Wege und die ersten Kontakte sind
gekn sie haben das ja sehr schön in
ihrer Rede gesagt man kann die Stadt
hochgas Glück wünschen für so ein
jameister unternehmerbürgermeister mot
Unternehmer
soforter Berlin
danke bisschen ach sehr sehr
schön dann sehen wir uns mal hier aber
sorgfältig
NES haben alle Hunger wir kommen hier
nicht Z mit
[Musik]
TCH Bürgermeister
Sandler sie stehen hier für dieses
Projekt Schloss weberberg von dem jeder
weiß dass es es gibt aber bislang keiner
offiziell laut drüber reden möchte dabei
ist es das größte Tourismusprojekt
Deutschlands das Investitionsvolumen
liegt roundut 450 Millionen Euro wenn
ich mich nicht täusche das hört sich ja
erstmal sehr gut an ne und ich glaube
auch dass hier wirklich wenn wir dann
mal gezielt in die Vermarktung gehen äh
großes Interesse auf Seiten der
Investoren sein wird die Einmaligkeit
rekrutiert daraus dass ich nicht nur ein
schickes Hotel und einen schicken
Golfplatz und dann noch ein bisschen
hereiter dazu mache das B ich an jeder
Straßenecke aber wenn ich fünf
Golfplätze baue und sechs Hotels dazu
stelle dann noch 35 bis 40 Hektar
Wasserfläche neu schaffe dann sind wir
sicherlich in der Lage dieses auch am
Markt zu platzieren die entsprechend
Betreiber zu finden und natürlich auch
die geldgeberung dazu zustellen wann
wird der ber aufs Gelände und wann wird
der erste Hotelgast sein Schlüssel in
die Tür schieben wir haben uns
aufgestellt und vorgenommen wir möchten
gerne Pfingsten Pfingsten 11 möchten wir
eröffnen
2011sten 2011 jetzt nur das Geld se
nicht so unruhig ST das werden wir
hinkriegen en Mistes rappelt in der
Kiste ne ene meene Maus und du bist raus
nein es läuft hier wie spretzelbacken
und von den 400 Millionen haben wir 285
schon
zusammen und die restlichen 115 die
schießen wir bis morgen Nachmittag um
ja ja jawohl Tom es ist spannend ne bis
dein guten Flug ne jo
tschüss komm um ab
oder er hat gerade
eingecheckt und sein Flieger geht wir
müssen ihm irgendwann mal deutlich
machen wenn du nicht begreifst dass das
was hier bei uns ist das Wichtigste
ist und du auch begreifst dass das auch
für dich das wichtig in deinem Leben ist
also das wir waren vor einem Jahr schon
maladolsen zusammengekommen und da sind
auch einige fun
wir sind im Projekt sehr viel
weitergekommen da sind wir also nicht
ein Jahr auf der Stelle getreten aber
was dieses Ansprechen von Betreib und
speziell angeht da sind wir nicht sehr
viel
weiter wir hatten eigentlich verabredet
in Frankfurt ganz speziell drei
anzusprechen Kinski Deutschland noch
einmal aufzusuchen ein Kontakt
herzustellen heigenberger und einen
Kontakt herzustellen mit Robinson das
waren die drei führenden leider muss ich
feststellen ist da nichts passiert ich
habe auch keine Signale von Tom bekommen
also nach dem der letzten Besprechung in
Frankfurt bin ich mit großer Sorge
aufgestanden das haben Sie gemerkt wir
haben uns da auch unsere Gedanken
gemacht ich
habe Leute angesprochen wo ich weiß dass
die wirklich sehr gute Kontakte in
Großinvestoren Szene haben bz selber im
großinvestorenbereich auf
Investorenseite tätig sind und wenn das
Signal das ist zu sagen wir müssen
gucken dass wir Leute ansprechen die da
wirklich mitwirken können und das mit
stemmen können ja dann möchte ich nicht
diese Kontakte aktivieren und nachher
sagen alles ablasen weil jetzt der Tom
grause gesagt hat er spricht die doch an
also da mache ich mich dann auch
lächerlich also ich hätte jetzt ehrlich
gesagt kein Verständnis zu sagen jetzt
hat er noch zwei
dreimal nach leg Chance weil das läuft
jetzt schon eine ganze Weile und und
entweder wir nutzen unsere Kontakte oder
lassen es sein also wenn das mit dem
grause nicht funktioniert dann musss der
Kuse aufhören ja also da ein bisschen
schwanger das geht nicht also das ist
viel zu wertvoll und noch mal ich bin
der FIS Überzeugung einmal falsch
angesprochen dann haben sie keine zweite
Chance
ja Apfelbacher mein Name ist hen satler
ja bin der Bürgermeister der stadof
Geismar sch und Frau Steu Benk hat
freundlicherweise den Kontakt
hergestellt und mir mitgeteilt der
affelbacher seid derjenige welcher in
dem Bereich von colliier ich denke um
sowas zu realisieren und um sowas zu
investieren wird zumindest bei uns im
Haus in dieser kleinen Einheit die
Expertise
[Musik]
fehlen aber nichtsdestotrotz sehr sehr
beeindruen
glauben sie
dassfinanzierung überhaupt denkbar wäre
und wenn ja was wen glauben Sie wer K da
in
Frage Finanzierung als also als
gschlossen V ich denke es ist ein
bisschen schwierig
weil h unheimlich viele Geld vorgehalten
werden müssen die aber erst zu einem
sehr späten Zeitpunkt ein Ertrag
abwerfen
wo ist wo ist dann der Anreiz für den
[Musik]
Investor
so
owner
noter
das Land
hen
only
Landwirtschaft
Landwirtschaft Agrikultur AG Land ja
Land
[Musik]
wiron
ja also die verschiedenen
Phasen die erste Phase ist die Hot das
da oder und die
Dörfer hier direkt W
all
inild pro
wow
okay
caned
iing all
[Musik]
go
okay Ludwig der
von
unfortunately little more
pragma you need vision and you need to
do more than simple go
simple how Sunny is area for
example is it Training a
lot is it is it a particularly beautiful
scenery I
think there sa book SA book is the
Don röchen
Schloss Don
röchen
homeleepon
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sleeping
beuty you have expression in English you
want Theiss Sleeping
Beauty
to ja ja ja ja
okayk so das war der zweite Kal ich habe
das gewusst ich wollte das Kämpfen
ja
[Musik]
hallo Tom hier ist hen satler
hallo Tom mein lieber ich fahre gerade
hier in in K auf der
corsette und und und denke an dich und
habe und habe den Eindruck du hast du
hast uns nicht mehr
lieb ach du bist in Abu
Dhabi ja hör mal du soll du sollst dich
nicht da um die um die German city da in
Abu Dhabi kümmern du soll dich um bberwg
kümmern da muss dein Herz da muss dein
Herz
schlagen in Abu Dhabi hast du BWG
vorgestellt der alles schießen
will alles
komplett und sind das sind das sind das
Araber oder sind das Amis oder was ist
das für
aus
abuabi
[Musik]
ratenschaft